[Music]
when i was five years old and my elder
sister was just starting
school my dad quit his steady job
he came home and told my mum i'm going
to start my own business
my mum burst into tears
they had two kids and a mortgage how
were they to make ends meet
my dad didn't come from immense
privilege he never earned a bachelor's
degree
but he was hungry for success and wanted
better for his children
so he scrapped together all of his
savings and invested everything into his
new advertising business
after five years of hard work the
business was struggling
and his co-founders quit undeterred
my dad remortgaged our house to raise
funds and pressed on without them
over the next 20 years he painstakingly
bootstrapped his business
taking measured risks and working
relentlessly to ensure the success of
his organization
he worked tirelessly to provide a better
life for his family
and today his business employs over 50
people
although my accent portrays the fact
that my dad's success was in australia
rather than america my dad lived his own
version
of the american dream
but my dad was one of the lucky ones we
know that today
for most people the american dream is a
myth
64 of the wealth of the united states is
held by the top 10
of families a child's chance of earning
more than his or her parents
has plummeted from 90 to 50
and the key determinant of your
financial outcome in life
is whether you were born into a wealthy
family
america has a long history of systemic
racism and unequal access to opportunity
many remedies have been proposed and
many remedies are needed
but i'm a tax nerd and from my
perspective
one important remedy is to reshape our
tax code
so that we focus on taxing wealth rather
than income
yes my friends this is a talk about
taxes
my father accumulated his wealth through
hard work
and he paid his fair share of income
taxes
but our tax code can't end there
his net his wealth now self perpetuates
more wealth
and i as his son and one of the
undeserving
beneficiaries so how does a tax
nerd like myself propose to change this
dynamic
i want to suggest two possible wealth
taxes
first an inheritance tax
an inheritance tax also known as an
estate tax
is a tax on the assets transferred from
deceased persons
to their heirs inheritance taxes
have a long history augustus the first
roman emperor
imposed the tax on 1 20th of inheritance
in 6 a.d
in the u.s the first inheritance tax was
adopted in 1797
but recently inheritance taxes have been
on the decline
in 1976 the highest inheritance tax
in america was 77 percent
today it is just 40 percent
simultaneously the exemption threshold
the amount that can be passed down
tax-free has continuously risen
with the tax reform in 2017 the tax-free
threshold
for estate taxes is 22.8 million dollars
for married couples
let me say that again today if you are a
married couple with less than 22.8
million dollars in assets
you don't pay a dollar of estate tax
some see this situation as justified
there is a righteous belief
among some that american freedom demands
that people should be able to hand their
private property to their children
and that any estate tax represents
dreaded double taxation
they say my parents have already paid
tax on these assets
why should they have to pay them again
but these arguments overlook the fact
that a significant portion of family
wealth is earned from
unrealised capital gains that is the
increase in the value of
assets like stocks and bonds
these unrealized capital gains have
never been taxed
and more importantly the people who
inherit the estate
have done nothing to earn this
inheritance
i ask again why am i entitled to the
fruits of my dad's hard work
letting fortunes pass across generations
risks creating
a hereditary elite this is antithetical
to america's spirit of rewarding
enterprise
above bloodline the constitution
prohibits the u.s government from
granting
titles of nobility so why should
americans allow nobility
in all but title
for those like myself who treasure the
dynamism and innovation of the american
economy
and inheritance tax is one of the most
efficient ways for the government to
raise revenue
unlike income taxes they do not reduce
the incentive to work unlike capital
gains taxes
it doesn't dissuade saving or investment
and
unlike sales taxes it's progressive
as we search for efficient ways to help
close the wealth gap
inheritance taxes are part of the answer
in 2019 american raised just 17 billion
dollars from its inheritance tax
if instead we were willing to tax
estates above a million dollars
with a progressive rate structure
starting at 30 percent
and going up to 75 percent for estates
above 20 million dollars
we would be able to raise approximately
130 billion dollars
annually
but inheritance tax by itself is not
enough
and economists have another tool to help
close the wealth gap
we also need to implement a national
land value tax
a land value tax is an annual percentage
tax
say three percent on the value of only
the land
it is different from a property tax
because it excludes the value of the
house or building sitting on the land
economists love land taxes
in 1978 milton friedman declared it the
least
bad tax and even earlier henry george's
book on land taxes
progress and poverty sold more copies in
america
in the 1890s than any other book
except the bible the reason for this
popularity
at least among economists is that
typically taxing a good
lowers supply and raises price it's for
this reason
that we tack cigarettes to deter smoking
or tax gasoline to deter frivolous
driving
but land is different in that its supply
is fixed
and as long as land owners are competing
with each other for renters
whose numbers and willingness to pay are
unaffected
the tax should not be passed on in
higher rents
the other reason taxing land values is
so adored by nerdy economist
is its fairness no person has a moral
claim on the land itself
and when the government builds roads
installs lights
and expands transport lengths the value
of land
increases without any effort from the
landowner
no landowner deserves these windfall
gains
the value of land in america is
estimated at 23
trillion dollars a national land value
tax of 3 percent
would raise almost 700 billion dollars
for the government
every single year this could be used to
help close the wealth gap
improving education for our children and
health care
for us all i'm not delusional
these tax reforms alone won't end
inequality
inequality is a deeply rooted issue in
our society
that will take a coalition of
politicians advocates
and business leaders years of hard work
to change
but i'm hopeful that tax reforms can be
a part of the solution
my mother and father should enjoy the
wealth that they have created
over a lifetime of hard work but while
they are alive
a land value tax should ensure that
their wealth is not enriched by
windfall gains of property prices and
when they pass away
i hope i live in a society where any
wealth they leave behind
is donated or taxed
[Music]